good afternoon good morning to some of
you I'm Niger tarasova I had what's
called synthetic biologics and Drug
Discovery facilities at the National
Cancer Institute and Frederick Maryland
we're a group of chemists I will
introduce the group at the end of my
talk but the major thing we do is
creation of chemical biology tools for
cancer research and use them for better
understanding the pathways involved in
human development and also
investigating the properties of
potential drug targets
a very interesting open Forum which was
called why haven't we cured the cancer
yet
and these were the challenges discussed
before
tumor heterogeneity from one patient to
another tumor heterogeneity from Once to
myself to another we have big problems
compensating for the loss of tumor
suppressors inactivated by mutations
we do not understand really well how the
drivers in cancer cells look and for
many
oncoproteins we cannot develop any drugs
and they're considered to be
non-druggable
it's sort of obvious why it's important
and challenging to inhibit non-druggable
on the proteins but why do we need to
understand really well how the drivers
encounters
and this is because
our lack of detailed understanding of
mechanism of tumors
of
drivers function
do influence the outcomes in the clinics
so this is a almost classical example
um but here we have a patient who has a
bureau of mutant
and many companies have developed
um
inhibitors for ear off kinase and as the
majority of molecular retargeted drums
those compounds do make tumors to
respond and significantly A reduced
tumor burden initial
however again as with majority of
molecular targeted drugs tumors the
regrow and if you compare
um A and C you can see that these are
the same tumors
so genetic Studios
helped us understand what's going on in
the majority of cases
and we know now that tumors regrow
because they are multi-clonal they're
heterogeneous
so and um
simply in this case would have a very
gross and many kinds of other cases but
it grows of clothes that are independent
of the mutation
um however in this particular case
Bureau it was beautiful Inhibitors then
you can notice uh looking at the time
scale of those pictures that it seems
that in the presence and in really
towards the case
um we have accelerated human growth
week 15 to week 23.
that um
the inhibitors
um that inhibit growth of Bureau of
dependency cells
can stimulate
the growth of cells that do not have
mutation in there
so and
what's remarkable so the discoveries of
those out inhibitory
mechanisms have been made with the help
of the Inhibitors themselves
so and it's really a Pity that we knew
this I learned about this only after the
Inhibitors got into the cleaning because
if we had known earlier
um
uh um different schedule
um would have been used
in getting a complaint but the building
was low
so you know and there are many other
questions you know the short message is
that we did doing it no
um those tiny details of signaling of
any uncontrolled team that we need to
inhibit
but they are very complex
and
it's let's look
at an example of one of my favorite
proteins and Stat 3 which is a
transcription factor is not exceptional
in this working it is a large protein
but as many proteins that we don't want
inhibiting
um cancer it is multifunctional and it
is involved in many protein protein
interactions so 116 are known and listed
in human protein reference database
so staggering number so and
um all six domains countries composed
though
um can be involved in numerous protein
Protein Solutions so one can envision
and that there are many those
interactions surfaces on the surface of
static proteins so indefinitely
um many partners bind through
overwrapping surfaces but some of them
bind total independency
and again every binding event
potentially produces a signal leading to
a biological event
so um
the most commonly used methods of
studying proteins are still genetical
methods sirna and genome carbons but the
problem was then that they abrogate all
signals and definitely
um none of outer inhibitory loops and
loop sort of and feedback loops could be
discovered this way
so what we in reality want is to
interrupt
one interaction or at least a group of
interaction at a time
small molecules and in general chemical
probes can do that
but the problem with them is the
development
so first of all many more than half of
suspected on conscience products are
non-druggable so here then highlighted
in yellow
and even if they are druggable
it takes significant amount of time
effort and funds to develop those
inhibitors
so and again we want to inhibit protein
protein interactions because they
believe so all biological and signaling
events however
because um
protein protein interaction
involve a large interactive surfaces
it's obviously fairly hard for a small
molecule to compete with this
multi-point interactions and it has been
estimated that only between 5 and 15
percent of protein protein interactions
can indeed be inhibited by small
molecules and small molecule by
definition has molecular weight of less
than 500 kilonewtons and again it's a
huge effort to identify them by the
screening techniques
so the method
an alternative method that sort of lies
on the surface is to use memetics of
interaction surfaces so potential that
it can be used as the negative
Inhibitors of corresponding interaction
so however there is a problem of using
peptides
as fragments as mimetics of proteins
because
um
they do not maintain the original fold
that they have the in the protein
without scaffolding by the rest of the
molecule so the movie
um that we're about to present
demonstrate molecular Dynamic simulation
and this are over Helix and what happens
to it in solution when you remove the
rest of the protein I would appreciate
if you could show in the movie clip now
the Moon is not plain but
um
so multiple approaches have been
developed to stabilize a known fault of
peptides
in the regional Foundation
and the majority of those approaches
involve cyclization that was applied
both to helices or helices and to higher
pins
however there are significant
limitations first of all
it's again not very easy approach second
frequently the bridge is used to form
the Helix
um do distort the structures in a way
that doesn't allow you to do it really
in any way you want
and
still these things require knowledge of
detailed knowledge of the structure of
the protein complexity
so um we have found them to tell the
truth quite unexpectedly that there is
much easier way to stabilize the
structure of small peptides
and this is just by anchoring the
peptide through lipidation to Cellular
membrane or any membrane
and what's remarkable about this method
that it can be applied to any type of
secondary structure but it's stretched
helicopeptide or a heavy
and
What's Happening Here is that the
majority of
protein fragments
amphiphilic
this just comes from the way proteins
fold so they all have
hydrophobic form and any protein part
faces with one side this hydrophobic
core and aqueous solution
on the other side
so on when you attach this any fragment
to the membrane the pump it usually
faces the core
um I will prefer to interact with the
membrane however this interaction is
very dynamic
you can describe it rather like
snorkeling not diving into the membrane
peptide Moves In and Out
and stabilization is better described in
the amount of time peptide and
depends in the confirmation that is
designed
here we have an example of a peptide
that has two peptides that have exactly
same sequence but one is lipidated by
attachment of palmitic acid and the
other is not lipidated and here is see
this spectrum that have been taken in
the presence of membrane mimicking
micelles
so non-lipitated peptide
um spectrum of which is in blue shows um
typical
um random coil CD Spectrum while
lipidated peptide
um forms almost perfect humans
but also
very useful
for lipidated peptides is that they sell
Chronicle
so and they localize to all cellular
membranes whether it's nuclear
um or plasma membrane so and many of
them also penetrate nucleus not all of
them but mainly do
and of course you know practically all
Targets that would want to investigate
in cancers are inside the cells so this
is a technology so using the approach
you will have developed quite a number
of
important and selective inhibitors for
non-druggable proteins of Interest so
um this table lists some of them with
corresponding references that you can
look up although some of them have not
been published but I'm going to talk
about them a little bit more today
so uh how do we do that so definitely
um the strategy for the development of
the inhibitor which is again purely
rational depends on the amount of
structural information
so the easiest case an ideal
if um one has the structure of the
protein protein complex
um in our practical
life
we could never perfect situation but the
closest we came was was a step three
protein
um and
we decided to develop a compound that
would be dominant negative inhibitor for
n-terminal domain of cell three because
it was even termed protein interaction
domain and it was believed
um to be involved particularly
uh in
formation of tetramazole step three
three the problem
was that um
there are no structures for stat three
but there was structures for very close
relatives
another problem was that there was more
than one structure
the crystal structure predicted one mode
of interaction
okay close contact some kind of mouse to
Mouse while enema structure which was
again obtained in slightly different of
organizations on the page so the diamond
like this
but in both cases um
uh the second
and terminal Helix which is highlighted
here in red was involved in structure
formation so we have prepared
derivatives of this
Helix not only for stat three but for
for other members of the family
and characterized them careful and
indeed they turned out to be specific
for the corresponding stud protein and
that was published quite some time ago
in 2007.
but the interesting story
started late and this is kind of
typically I guess
um development of the events because
when you apply I mean chemical problems
be expected to get unexpected results
so and
it was very difficult particularly at
that stage to overcome everybody's
mentality so people usually think that
if you develop an inhibit
you should obtain same biological
effects as with s irony
or with gin knockouts
I think it's kind of almost obvious that
you cannot because with chemical probes
were inhibiting only subset protein
protein interactions that I showed
before while gym knockouts
take care of all of that
so but nonetheless it was quite
surprising because um
a collaborator of mine professor
from Georgetown University
um has done tremendous amount of work
with those inhibitors
trying to figure out what was going on
because
um the first result was quite unexpected
she did um
microallery analysis of gene expression
changes upon treatment of breast and
prostate
cancer cells with the Inhibitors and the
Inhibitors of star 3 and domain in
sort of behaved in the predicted way so
she saw a lot of
um
expression of the genes going down as
you would expect for a transcription
Factor well we start three
the total picture was the opposite so
the majority of the genes went up in
expression so again you know
transcription fact is supposed to
stimulate transcription you know to
inhibit it so while by inhibiting it we
would get
um elevated gene expression
so then she compared it to the results
of the soil RNA and in case of a
sirening really still margins went up in
expression however significant
um went down and there was significant
overlap in the genes that were
upregulated by the chemical probe and
assign RNA which kind of
um was a little bit comforting for us
not for the reviewers of the paper
and um
what was also interesting so that
the majority of the genes that you're
operating awaited by the compound
fall into the category of proportional
genes
that suggested that um step three
um inhibits expression a bunch of
productive genes and of course you know
the compounds
um the Inhibitors were quite toxic for
tumor cells
and it was quite promising and
astounding at the moment and at the very
beginning that um are both prostate and
breast cancer cells sensitive to the
compound while it had very little
toxicity on normal cells
so that's why
um Olga went all the way trying to
figure out what was going on
and um she showed that the inhibition of
internal domain of structure indeed
decreases statutory binding to Chronic
yeah
and it looks for mostly for
non-phosphorylated Star Trek that was
always considered to be inactive
transcription Factor
so that's why you know it was quite
difficult to publish those results it
was sort of
um going against common knowledge
um then um she confirmed by a chief kpco
that indeed that three interacted with
um physically interacted with the
promoters of the genes that were
are upregulated by exposure to the
inhibit
so and um to make this launch story
shown so the application of those
Inhibitors allowed to uncover a new
function of that three that is
definitely
um
a very promising function to Target in
humans
so our own result three suppresses
transcription of crop alternative genes
in cancer cells with the involvement of
internal domain
so that in terminal domains of stat
transcription factors not just
stuttering a promising drug targets and
what's very interesting that it showed
that we can reprogram transcription
factors and net reprogramming rather
than completely inhibiting
transcriptional activity with synthetic
molecules presents
um
potentially
useful therapeutic approach that may
provide powerful tools for the treatment
of many pathological conditions
so the next case that I'm gonna
talk about is
a little bit more complex so but very
common scenario
when we have a 3D structure
or the protein
of one of the problems involved in the
interactions
and
but the structure of the complex is not
available
and um
this particular example concerns with a
very popular oncogen
Okay Ross
and although there are several
structures of
Keras complexes with its effectors not
all of them are available and many of
them are incomplete because
um
for instance and the complex of uh kras
with rough kindness is is not available
particularly for the foldings
kinase just because
nobody was able to crystallize
so that's why in our studies of careers
we decided to assume
on that we don't know any structures
because indeed we don't know many and we
simply dissect it
um the structure of Keras which is known
um by secondary structure elements and
generated liquid times of those separate
sources
um bitter tones and so forth and simply
use the cell toxicity essays on cells
that have different degree of Keras
dependency as a readout to select the
regions that may be essential and maybe
um
promising as
dominant negative Inhibitors in studying
um Keras function
and two regions stood out immediately
and that was hyper variable region the
very sea Terminus of Keras that gets um
significant post-translational
modifications and including
fertilization
and over Helix number five that is
adjacent to a hypervical region
so um so we have at this point much more
data on hypervariable region that's why
I'm focused on and again are we um we
have chosen Keras as a Target because
um liquidation
is natural it took care of us
and in general when we started using
peptides the sort of
realized that um
and this is the modification that is
widely used by Mother Nature and
thousands of the proteins are known to
depend on
lipidation and membrane anchoring to
fold
so and chaos is definitely one of them
so it does need membrane anchoring for
the function
so but going back to a hyper variable
region so those um memetics liquidate
magnetics um helped us to uncover a new
level of Keras function regulation so
the first unexpected the result was that
those lipopeptides
that are new Matrix or Piper variable
origin
um bind to keyhouse itself
both in lipidated and non-regregated
form also and that they interact with
ikeras
active signed active
catalytic domain in a nucleotide
here are some switches between inactive
GDP loaded and active signaling GTP load
State and it turned out so this was a
microscale certain Services experiment
that used
fluorescent
cheras so and then it clearly shows that
um
um The Binding of hvr is much tighter to
inactive GDP modifications which is in
blue then to active flow GDP
here so our a long time collaborator
might even component kind of his
graduate students and and on my chairman
um investigated the interaction by
enema and um to everybody which is a big
surprise the interaction
the chemical shifts that they obtain the
hsqcl are Spectra indicated that
interaction occurs through um what's
called switch one region so the region
where many effectors of Keras Dubai
used molecular Dynamic stimulation to
obtain sort of high resolution picture
of hvi interaction with keros and um
um those studies predict that um hvr
forms absolutely beautiful extension of
beta-shaped
Performing what's called switch one
region of the Keras protein and what was
particularly remarkable that this
interaction structurally was very much
similar to interaction of krig keros
with
a rough communities
so and then we compared this
structure of hvr and binding interface
with that of other
factors and there was significant
overlap with as I mentioned it was
um interface
that is involved in interaction Reserve
but not too much so with
um
nucleotide exchange factors these are
factors that I needed for KRS activation
and then we evaluated the effects of hvr
analogs on interaction experimentally
and then turned out that hvr
significantly interferes was binding of
around to sort of inactive GDP
Unbound Keras but
um in foolings chaos will become hvr
present as a matter of fact interaction
with um
a rough increase suggesting that in
active form hvr facilitates interaction
while in the inactive form of Keras it
prevents interaction
and that um I think is a very
interesting
functional conclusion
um
many proteins in particular in
kerosmic signaling Cascade including
um receptor tires in Kinesis exist in
how to inhibited state so our
application of hvr um
chemical biology tool I suggest strongly
that kras also
exists as an auto inhibited State and
um we now assume that a major function
of this interaction is totally inhibit
totally suppressed the signaling from
GTP bound Keras
foreign
to the third case and I think um in the
third case of inhibited design is the
most vicinity negative one because none
of other methods um
of rational
development of Inhibitors do not allowed
to develop Inhibitors in the
total absence of structural information
and um
an example I think is almost perfect for
that
so we use this methodology to develop
inhibitors for interferon gamma receptor
and for I'll 10 receptor one
so and we wanted to inhibit the
cytoplasmic domain
because other groups
made an effort to inhibit The receptors
from outside
so we decided to do it from the inside
so but the problem with the receptors is
that the acetoplasmic domains belong to
the class of so-called intrinsically
features so not only there is no crystal
structure
likely to emerge soon unless we start
screening some kind of complexes
with partners that make those domains
for
so and here we um rely on
evolutional conservation
so the assumption is here
other
um
if certain parts are involved in
essential protein protein interactions
they must be conserved during the
evolution
and
indeed so if you're align with the
sequences of different gamma receptor
from different species several regions
stand out so
full of them
the function of
two of them is known so one of them
combines a job kinase which is necessary
for signaling through the receptor
another one is involved it gets violated
by kinase and is involved in interaction
with type 1 transcriptions while the
functional
what's called here B and D Parts it's
totally unknown although
previous I guess
or truncated and receptor indicated that
you see the very same Terminus of it
is essential for the function
so again we generated lipopeptides
corresponding to all of those um
highly conserved domains and these are
the potency of the inhibitors
when we're testing them not only
um
by Eliza
is using
this is that one
interference gamma induced for
sperulation what's that one in um
tumor cells
um so and um
if we go to the chemistries
um that we use that's you know practical
important question of course so two of
them are very straightforward and can be
used in any Laboratory
and because most of them
peptide synthesis now is being
outsourced to cover facilities or
companies that specialize in custom
peptide synthesis and um
simpler
um
a teaching fading Essence either um
to a side chain of Lysine residue or
even easier to the n-terminus on the
peptide
um
is um
very inexpensive and very easy to
perform procedure
in our lab we also have generated
several derivatives of alkyl our names
um that um
stabilize mostly Alpha helical
confirmation so we can attach those and
lately we have also developed
zincatalyze alkylation of cysteine
residue so this way you also can
um
introduce and
on fully Carbonite chains and through a
system presently
and um
those compounds lipopeptide analogs can
be used not only
in vitro
also we have used them successfully in
several occasions in animals for animal
studies we usually generate peptides
made of all the amino acids using what's
called a retro and rather old
technological retrain Wilson where the
sequence of the peptides is used to be n
terminals becomes C Terminus and minus
and every amino acid residue is
converted or used in density form
and
you're not guaranteed to get an active
compound by a retrained lotion from El
peptides because as a matter of fact so
um they are usually much more rich
um
however in our practice we haven't come
across
the small where the activity will be
killed opposite way around in several
cases since um deep up times are usually
more rigid we get Improvement of the
activity or at least in state with the
sum well however you know I cannot
exclude a disability that sometimes Red
Train version
um can compromise activity it will be
probably like it to some extent but it
also shows that this
kind of approach can be used rather
widely to generate physiological stable
peptides
um to use in animal systems so here we
have example of a stat one
undermine inhibitor used
of inflammatory breast cancer and you
can see that it significantly prolonged
survival in those animals and the three
endometer used in the same model
of breast cancer which is again
isagenic model which means that it uses
animals with intact immune system so in
this case um we have a significant
reduction in along with metastasis and
this otherwise High limited static
approach tumor motor
and
um
as a peptide chemistry and I had took
I'll leave through
a long um
sort of period of criticism
and I was told in many occasions that
clients cannot be found and that was
kind of common attitude so not any
movement because peptides nowadays
um
are not used so only as
chemical biology tools so yeah one of
the fastest growing classes of drugs in
the cleanings in 2012 Alone
um seven out of 31 man
new molecular entities approved by the
devil in the pept times and for peptides
that are currently in the clinics and
they invited this table are times
so which means that at least you know
when developing those
um
and as you can see it's very much
rational very much straightforward
approach that can be used in many
operators because
peptides can be outsourced
um
also
I'm gonna touch it briefly on a
different class of
peptide chemical biology tools that have
been developing also
and these are self-assembling
definitely viruses evolve this perfect
delivery system
and that's why
I cannot frequently
um quote anything Gaudi famous um
architect who said that nothing is
invented for its written in nature so
and um
that's why
um
I went forgot um
self-assembling fully synthetic
peptide that's the first thing that came
along that it is indeed a virus-like
structure
so and
um I wish you know we designed those
systems
pure regressionally
but I think at least we should be
credited for the fact that we simply
looked carefully and discovered that
some analogues of the transparent brain
peptides when they're put into water can
self-assembledon
so um it feels to be developed um
dominant negative
inhibitors for
membrane spinning multi-membrane
screening proteins particular for G
protein coupled receptors and we found
that if you make analogs of some
transmembrane domains and provide them
with negative charges on the end
supposed to be extracellular so that
they Orient themselves appropriately
during the insertion to the membrane you
can interfere with correct assembly of
it
corresponding
point however when you throw those
otherwise here we go times in what
they form seeds
and
this is a kind of stitching
um the aggregate with each other but if
you provide for additional pendulate
tail
so they become an escomogeneous is any
viral particle and as a matter of fact
the more than 99.9 homogeneous in size
foreign
particles that do not aggregate
so we use this um approach and
um
developed
a regular peptide that um
not all the self-assembles this amazing
Precision but it can be applied in
animals without any further
stabilization because this self-assembly
protects itself protects the peptide
from degradation with the proteins
so pigulation is essential because it
prevents not only aggregation but as we
suspected also protects us from
protolytic cleavage they are quite
so um however you know they did resemble
in terms of assembling virus-like
particles and we decided to make
this resemblance to virus like particles
even better because as you know
viruses are known for the ability to
enter only certain type of cells in
receptiny dated man
so that's what we decided to do to our
virus-like particles and
um definitely being in cancer field for
very long time so we have been mostly
interested in developing particles that
would be
um
selective for tumors
viruses are known also to enter uh cells
utilizing cell surface receptors
interaction with those so that's why we
decided to create this synthetic
and
um
to go and we talked ahead of myself I
should until that we did succeed in
doing so and
um
it's purely synthetic probably this is
the very first
virus-like particle that was synthesized
purely from scratch and it consists from
several parts that could sort of color
coded on this picture so one provides
both self-assembly but also it has
biological activity because the language
started so those peptides were just
dominant negative Inhibitors of some
decorating compact receptors so then we
have the pigulated
version of them so this Peg makes them
non-sticky so that's because if you
don't have these things so you do have
self-assembling those spherical
particles but they do aggregate
so and that you can
put um
receptor ligands to them so
they fuse with cells just like real
viruses and receptinitated
I should also point out that this poly
pink
coat not all the equivalents from
aggregation and makes the particles
uniform but it also
um
slows down selfish it sort of hides the
hydrophobic core because this plept time
is derived from transmembrane portion of
the target receptor
so our original book on
those transmembrane Inhibitors was done
with the protein coupled receptors
particularly for cxcr4 receptor that is
known to be an essential one in
human metastasis particularly in the
lung
so and the resulting
communities consists of self-assembling
part that also is an antagonist for
cxcr4 receptor so thank you prevents of
assembly but what also so we copied from
real viruses in this particular case
away on top of tank we put receptor
ligament for The receptors that are
known to the overexpressed in tumor
sounds and we chose
um to work with
receptors that are over expressed on the
surface of prostate cancer cells and to
make the launcher long story and it's
looks like a straightforward thing but
we went through
many neurons of optimization of penguins
um
the number of negative charges that we
went add to the
transmembrane portion of the receptor
that we're inhibiting and also
investigating different targeted
molecules but however we did generate
fully synthetic virus-like particles
that self-assemble like real viruses so
all you need to do is throw it in
homogeneous preparations
they do fuels with cells like real
viruses and receptividated
um Mana and if you're attached to any
load in this particular case the amount
is simply fluorescent point that we
needed to visualize the fusion they
delivered the whole thing to tumor cells
so far we use them as Imaging agent so
we put um infrared imagining time and
image prostate tumors
demise and you can see that um
they do make a
humans
are very bright so and here we have a
two types of tumors the one that has the
receptor and the one that doesn't have
the result and you can see the the
tumors with the receptors do um
light up
so um
and these are the people who did develop
and
where Muslim chemists although we have
but we're just in the group here in
stefanisca and I have lots of talented
um young men who join and girls and boys
who joined the group through
um
internship program of the National
Cancer Institute
and many of them
are becoming material scientists now
particular
is looking for a company now but um
definitely we're just group of chemists
and the collaborative extensively of
course in structural Languages by a
physicists
biologists and
have lots of very productive
collaborations
outside NCI
thank you very much for attention and
I'm ready to answer any questions you
may have
so and I should say that the funding
for the research was provided mostly for
by inside but also by DOD prostate
cancer program that funded our
development of those fully synthetic
wires like particles targeting
prostitute prostate tumors and also by
collaborative research agreement with
common interests that is helping us to
develop compounds thank you for us
so and I'm having a question from
um
thanks for the compliment
the question is how do we confirm that
particular lipopeptide inhibitor binds
to desired site of transcription Factor
so that is really
um
challenging things so the troll says
that in the majority cases
um we don't know where it binds exactly
so in case of um a stop transcription
factors for instance
we had access to
um
and domains and we could do NMR so it is
the looking at The Binding side
so however I think it's a common problem
with
Inhibitors that have multi-point
interactions and bind to signaling in
case of step four that we evaluated for
binding to the inhibitor
there was significant change in
significant conformation change in
almost in time
so in that sense
um
it was kind of a tiny bomb so it's fun
um foreign
however this is what what was exactly
that we wanted at this point definitely
it's going to be very difficult to
interfere
just with one protein protein
in terms because with this um
scale with multiple protein protein
interactions definitely they're going to
be over my opinions
repeated interaction
at least it's much better than
so there is another question
um
I would like to ask now how do you
confirm that the particular lipopeptide
inhibits the binds to design site of
transcription fact I'm so interested how
do studies 3D structure or peptide
embedded in my cell and whether lipid
composition influence peptide 3D
structure
foreign
for the
sort of partially answered your question
that we do solution anymore whenever we
can so same we did with
um Ross for instance and same we do for
the same we did for the N terminal
domain of stat transcription Factor our
collaborator within component who is the
animal spectroscopist uh performed this
time so but that's still frequently the
case that
um you did get frequently Global
rearrangements because these are
signaling molecules so they are kind of
designed to function in a way that small
changes in one part of the molecule
generates significant changes on the
other part
so and um
um but this basically the way we do it
we follow interaction by NMR and that
would allow us at least to localize
where the binding site is for another
um we're able to have access to the
sufficient amount of the protein
so um how do we study 3D structure of
peptide embedded in my cell
and whether lipid composition influence
peptide 3D structure
um
um we sort of you know do in most of the
cases really low resolution studies
using City spectroscopy and
the
cool the
property of the mic so
um does influence defaulting first of
all muscles are not perfect
mimetics of
and we have campaigns side by side
folding of liquidated peptides in Bice
cells and in my cells so usually you get
much better for the in bisons
um but this is really kind of a low
resolution structure we just followed by
City spectross okay however
usually
just judging from City spectroscopy the
degree is folding is pretty good
so how do we confirm that particular
lipopeptide inhibitor binds to desired
side of transcription Factor that's
Again by using animal remembrance
so I'm also interested how to study 3D
structure of peptide in my in my cell
and where the lipid composition
influence type 3D structure so we kind
of you know do in most cases a very
um
hello resolution CD Spectrum
and as I mentioned so yes the Olympic
composition
influences the folding
um
significantly just what we um have been
able to observe comparing myself and
biceps and which I'll play
um we did it mostly by cities
spectroscopy people haven't done solid
state animal or I could suggest that
that must be always feasible
and with
low resolution
methods like TDS spectroscopy
um
we cannot afford kind of screaming many
lipids because we are limited to use of
lipids that um
are not optically active otherwise
messages Spectrum gets really messy
thank you
foreign
s like particles can induce inflammatory
inflammatory response um
first of all um virus like um
particles are sort of not biologically
in the other thing in terms of that they
have embedded
um activity so they are made of
self-assembling peptide that has
biological activity
so far we have investigated an advanced
that inhibit a function of certain
duplicate coupled results
so we haven't seen any inflammatory
responses although to tell the truth we
have been using them mostly in animals
as compromised immune system
um
however to defend them a little bit
inflammatory responses are unlikely
um because particles are fairly small
this is an advantage but it's also a
drawback
so they are about between 10 and 12
nanometers in the end
um
so that's why
there is no visible inflammatory because
and it's unlikely to be one even in
animals with immune system however it's
also a drawback because um
I would like you know for certain
applications than to the bigger so that
we can direct them into certain types of
tissues and cells but deservativity and
this is you know one of the research
directions that will follow also that we
can
generate bigger
nanoparticles out of um particles okay
it's still ongoing so I also didn't
mention the recovering another wonderful
properties so they have hydrophobic core
that can trap
um
hydrophobic drugs so they can be also so
far investigated them as Imaging agent
and we're developing them as
um radiotherapeutics in that sense
pheronautics
um and
although originally to tell the truth
um
the original goal was to develop them as
delivery agents but however it turned
out that the size that we're engaging
from what we have now is too small to
allow them with large amount of cargo
inside they do have hydrophobic and they
can trap hydrophobic drugs like
toxol for instance delivering so but by
working on increasing the size so that
we can
deliver more however definitely the
larger the particle the more likely the
immune responsible so
um not a little bit differently watching
for that however again Peg is a normal
kind of stealth coating
compounded partially
can protect them from
importances
so the other question is I would like
also to know if virus-like particles can
induce inflammatory response so I sort
of partial I think answer to that one so
because
um
first of all we haven't seen any but
that could be because they're fairly
small
and second they are quoted with
pro-ethylene recall that is known to
make themselves invisible for the immune
system
so another question
um I would like to ask how would you
confirm that particular deep peptide
inhibitor binds to desired site of
transcription Factor so by doing by NMR
spectroscopes classical
um a comparison of chemical shifts with
and without inhibition
and also in terms of transcription
Factor so in case of um step three we
did it by um
fluorescence resonance energy transfer
we use the
stock 3 that was tagged with green
fluorescent protein and we can since
we're a chemistry we can put any
fluorescent
itself so and we had exceptionally
powerful threat system that's which we
could quantitate
um so the other question is
um whether virus like particles can't
can induce inflammatory response I think
it will make them big enough they
probably can but we haven't seen
um this far and we use them both in
um animals with intact immune system and
in
new movies I think because they sort of
stealth accounted with uh
foreign
I would like to ask how do confirm that
particularly popular client inhibit the
binds to design site of transcription
facts and I'm also interested how do
studies like this structure part-time
embedded in my cell and whether lipid
compensation influence book time 3
destruction
so again
um
can we do it by um we started binding
mostly by MMR
the
that turned out to be
fairly sensitive way of doing that on
the not the cheapest one and you
definitely have to
um use high concentration of the
transcription fact itself or its part it
was the case instead of an increase of
step three
and for three destruction embedded in
myself the values and very low
resolution
approaches that's like City spectross
cooking
and with a lipid composition influence a
3D structure is
Institute we do see the difference
between
in folding of the peptide between bisols
and micelles and that could be a lipid
composition but most likely I think it's
the influence of the curvature of the
liquid so in my Souls that are very
small so pep 5 doesn't have the ability
to form all side chain interaction it
means for complete folding while in
bigger and more flat surface where it's
we have better mimic of them
membranes usually foldings much better
so there is also question whether
virus-like particles can induce
inflammatory various problems so far we
haven't seen any
entices if we
modify the surface so that um patient
doesn't cover it completely and
everything big enough
okay no more questions and thank you so
much